did you enjoy your time in London Eugene
did it was really great I had a really
good experience and like the production
like set me up at a nice gym just like
my new thing is working out like I've
never really done it and I'm really into
it now
and I mean I'd go like every once in a
while and like do little crunches but I
was working out there and I saw someone
really famous oh yeah really cool I saw
Prince Harry working out Prince Harry
yeah yeah lately where was he at the gym
but I know he was at the gym but you
said that you were on that like on the
same man we were on a little Matt doing
little stretches this is sounds like an
erotic adventure are you sure it was
amazing I was like I was down there
doing my little thing and then like I
noticed this guy helping someone work
out and he was dressed in like a
button-down and a tie like at the gym
which seemed really weird and I was like
that trainer is like very fancy maybe
he's like famous or maybe the guy he's
working with his famous and I was
looking at the guy like trying to be
really subtle and then I realized it was
Prince Harry so I just like did crunches
for like thirty more minutes than I ever
would were you inching your way over
incredible abstract
you